[Music]
courtney starts off this hour in
baltimore hi courtney welcome to the
ramsey show
hi happy monday thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i'm recently divorced um and i
have about which is the very thing and i
have about 60k in debt that i'm
struggling to tackle i've struggled the
process um i started the process of
doing a cash-out refinance with my home
since it has a ton of equity but since
my credit score is pretty low i'm going
through a broker and not a traditional
lender
so my monthly payment will be increasing
and my interest rate will be higher so
i'm starting to rethink my decision
but other than selling my home
which i really don't want to do i'm not
sure what other options i may have to be
able to get myself back in a better
financial situation
how long have you been divorced
um almost a year now so last august
everything was finalized
children
um yes one three-year-old
all right
and um what do you make of your
um about 100 101
okay
and what's the house worth
um
it's recent appraisal was for 4 30.
i purchased it for 150.
you purchased it
yes well you know i have my current
mortgage it's we
purchased it
you bought it with your ex right
no i purchased my home before i was
married oh okay and so you got the home
after okay so you owe 150
and you owe 60 and you make a hundred
yes
okay
all right
um well i i'm really glad that you gave
the second thoughts because it was a
mistake to refinance this yeah don't do
it don't do it don't do it yeah you're
getting ready to make an error and the
reason you're getting ready to make an
error was you're solving a short-term
problem with a long-term solution
and
and a bad one at that because you're
getting a higher interest rate and a
payment you can't afford and all that
kind of stuff
so what do you owe the sixty thousand
dollars on
um credit cards
okay
um and when has that popped up
um so they're credit cards that i
have had for about five years now
um
and
you've had this debt sixty thousand
dollars in for five years
um so i actually opened the account
within the last five years okay when did
you run up the debt
about five years ago
okay before the development
yes okay how much debt have you run up
lately
um
none uh because i don't have any
additional credit to try to run up
okay
so it's just paying minimum payments
with my
um
with my pace
how long were you married
uh about two years what do you do for a
living
i'm a public health researcher
would you believe us if we told you
that
with about 18 months of grinding it you
could be done
maybe 24 months
um it's hard to believe but if if you
think that's an option i can
mathematically it's an option okay okay
i mean
can i be mean for a second
sure you've got the same barrier that
i've got and that john has
the thing that's going to keep you from
doing it's the person in your mirror
yeah not the math you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year you got a
reasonably low house payment
um
and
you've treated this credit card debt
like it's cute
like it was something you swept under
the rug and didn't deal with it
emotionally
and you're hurting after a divorce even
though you called it a good thing it
still hurts
i'm guessing that's the father of your
child
and i'm guessing that i'm guessing that
it hurts
and um
you know so this is the time where you
say okay i'm gonna be like a grown woman
instead of a little girl and i'm going
to get
roll up my sleeves and attack this stuff
as a part of my healing and as a part of
my going forward in this future i've got
to get control of this part of me that's
was out of control and you actually said
the only reason you're not running up
more debt is just because they won't let
you
right not because you got under got
yourself under control
so i think you have a beautiful life
lesson to get you under control and
learn to trust you to not overspend
as you work your way out of this so this
tough 18 months on beans and rice and
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
working extra
selling everything in sight we're going
to be on a budget we're going to be on a
budget we're going to tell our money
what to do if you will do all of that we
can show you how to pay this off in 18
months it's only thirty thousand dollars
a year for two years and you make a
hundred
okay and you're done and then you don't
have to look and and go gosh the only
reason i didn't run up debt is because
they wouldn't let me you go the reason i
don't run up debt is it stupid and i'm
not a person that does that anymore i
used to be that person
and courtney one of the most common
things i hear from folks who just got
divorced is
uh whether even when like you said it's
a quote unquote good thing
is you lose that trust in yourself
right i thought it was going to look
like this i
thought this person was going to be like
this right
and if you will commit to 18 months of
grinding and out
you're getting after it you will find
yourself standing taller yeah you're
going to get your confidence find new
muscles that you don't have you will be
like yeah dude listen look at you'll be
i'm a warrior princess leave me alone
exactly and you know what else is cool
that three-year-old little girl is gonna
get to watch you too
she's gonna feel it in the other way oh
little boy that little boy is gonna
watch his mama he's gonna feel it in the
air this the air will change in your
house while you're fighting through this
does all that ring true to your heart
right now
it does okay uh definitely not
what i thought you were going to say but
i think that's what i need to see here
i think i think you have a huge
opportunity to fix you and the byproduct
is going to be the sixty thousand
dollars goes away in the process
okay it'll evaporate you learn to handle
this stuff in a grown-up way and you
throw your shoulders back and go yeah
baby game on
right and anytime money stuff comes at
you then you're in control of it it's
not in control of you for the rest of
your life and that's how people end up
becoming wealthy by the way we're going
to do we're going to take care of this
for you we're going to show you exactly
what to do we've got a nine week class
called financial peace university i'm
going to sign you up for that in ramsey
plus for free i'm not going to charge
you a dime for it because i think you're
a hero getting ready to happen and i
want to be part of the story okay
great thank you so much hey you promised
you'll do it
i already played put on hold on the
second is yes i'm taking it the answer
is the answer is she's going to do it so
and we're going to show you exactly what
to do in ramsey plus at financial peace
university with the every dollar app all
completely is our gift to you you're
you're ready you're the kind of person
and i'm really glad that that they you
know you didn't get that alone oh man
they're screwed up i love that line your
hero getting ready to happen yeah i like
it